it was a lot of fun on set really i
think when this matter is so intense
your brain automatically tries to like
cling on to any
form of comedy so if there's someone
tell us like a tiny not even something
funny on set everyone laughs for about
10 minutes because you're just looking
for a bit of comic relief once you once
you got that script and you and you saw
in it on the page kind of what did you
think of her when you first read her
i had seen something that i hadn't seen
done before so i think it was
she's someone who's incredibly complex
and she was difficult to pin down
and the journey that she goes on from
kind of beginning of the story right
through to the end is
it has such major shifts that to be
given the opportunity to explore
as an actor is very exciting and the one
thing
[Music]
i believed when i read it is that this
is someone who has experienced an
incredible
and childhood trauma and is suffering
with ptsd and i hadn't seen
and a character like this depicted on
screen especially by a woman it's
usually
by men in films that have returned home
from war and
for enid the trauma is that of hers of
the child and that's kind of shaped her
perception of the world and now you have
this adult that has
now working as a sensor
and she senses that she has this duty
like a soldier to protect the public
this depiction is dangerous come on
ain't no one's going to pick this up and
think it's the documentary it's so funny
you it might be sausages for intestines
but if it gets into the hands of
children exactly kids could be rewinding
and watching those scenes over and over
again which is exactly what new
government guidelines are pointing out
video technologies changing guidelines
great not as if we haven't gotten enough
on it how do we do our job properly if
we're constantly bogged down by
government bureaucracy it's the nation's
sanity they're worried about why don't
they stop slashing social services okay
i get it i'm afraid we're not here to
debate the government can we get back on
track please i kind of saw this
superhero on on the page that a very
kind of
you know alternative superhero
and who takes her job so incredibly
serious because she believes that she
serves as like this protector to put up
to the public protecting them from
seeing something traumatic that she's
experienced
and
i don't know i don't i don't know i
think that the idea of exploring a
character liking it within
genre
is very special because
[Music]
what anthony and prano have done is that
they have
created a character piece that delves
deep into psychological trauma
and
and the trauma
is something that
her
that event in her child's childhood is
the monster within within the script
every time i've seen the film and there
is so much
um sweetness in it
but she's such a suitcase full of trauma
as well so i'm wondering how do you
start breaking down the elements of the
character to start approaching her
yeah she's this is like a shoe suitcase
drama
and when i first looked at
ptsd
and
she's someone who
is who's the more ptsd someone who looks
for a threat everywhere
so it was important to look at the
triggers that set in it off in the story
and then begin working backwards from
there to establish her backstory her
family history and how
that traumatic event as a child in her
childhood like
ultimately shaped her as the adult that
she is in the story
he's calling for me
the evil is contagious
she
is losing so much of herself by the end
of the story but i feel like this is
someone who is like prana always
describes as like this tightly
wound spring and all of a sudden
once
something reminds her of this trauma she
kind of explodes but i think this is
someone who's actually also trying to
figure out who she is as a person she's
never really allowed herself to be seen
so you could go so far say this is
someone who
may have personality disorder and in
those moments where she has gone
insane and manic
to her that is she doesn't seem mad and
but for the audience you just see a
crazy person and i think that's the idea
of
how do you balance out
you know how do you balance out
what is real and what is unreal because
her tunnel vision of trying to find out
the truth is so muddy because
i suppose her playing field is muddied
when we were working on the idea very
early on i mean really from the very
seed of the idea for me
the film was as much about
self-censorship as it was about
censorship in film
um so i always knew that this was going
to be about a character who was scared
of what was inside them deep down that
they're scared perhaps that deep down
they're rotten that they're a bad person
and
we were always talking about this idea
that there was
something in enid's past that she
couldn't access that there'd been some
kind of
uh psychological censorship you know
we our brains can censor things for us
if we're not able to cope with
that memory or that experience at that
time and and it was actually kind of
when we when we kind of clicked on this
idea we explored a few different ideas
and and actually it was partly through
nasty that we landed on this idea that
you know her sister had disappeared and
we explored a lot that you know how that
had happened and what that memory was
and and this idea of enid feeling
responsible for that
and so i i researched um ambiguous loss
and that was at once really
heartbreaking
um but really helps to kind of set us
into enid's point of view this idea of
living
permanently with ambiguous loss which i
think is at the heart of
of censor
so it was listening to first person
accounts and
this idea of people who are constantly
looking constantly searching that they
can't switch off
and those kinds of ideas feed into the
script in moments where you see her
you know think that she sees her sister
in the alleyway
um
but the more i thought about ambiguous
loss the more we kind of explored these
ideas it felt like it really chimed with
some of the other themes we were
exploring which was
the relationship between fiction and
reality and this idea that
you know if you've suffered from
ambiguous loss there's a lot of
reliant on your imagination in terms of
well what happened that day where did
she go where is she now
um
that felt like it fed into this
this theme of of
you know this fiction and reality and
the conversation that happens between
fiction and reality and this idea that
enid's imagining
where her sister could be imagining what
might have happened there's different
versions of that story
she's filling the gap in her brain with
fiction and that is fueling her actions
in reality and fueling what happens next
and so you know it was really
interesting when you kind of find those
themes kind of clicking together the
film obviously takes place in the 80s
and we were saying you know like
if it was today she would probably have
gone to therapy and dealt with all the
stuff and we wouldn't have had a film
you know so that was always like this
kind of logic but you know like that
she's
she was also working within a climate
which which hopefully has changed a
little bit which didn't allow her to
deal with as neither says the ptsd that
she's got maybe you could help me i was
looking for
some of the more unusual
frederick north films
i've seen um
donkey in the church
huh
perhaps maybe you might have something
else of his under the counter
um
i've not seen you in here before
just moves the area
someone like you doesn't want to watch
films like that
like what
my favorite is uh stationary massacre
the repeated stabbing of the man's eye
with compass then his stomach being
ripped open with serrated scissors
his guts falling out his his stomach
being stapled back together
masterpiece
what's your favorite video nasty i mean
i'm a massive fan of the texas chainsaw
massacre which i actually saw recently
on 35 millimeter at the prince charles
and it was
uh just the sound and the pure dread of
that film is incredible but the witch
who came from the sea is a much less
well-known video nasty that i think is
kind of a masterpiece um
you know that's that would nobody would
even know about if it hadn't been
wrapped up in this list um but that's
would actually make quite an interesting
double bill i think with censors this
kind of woozy nightmare um about a woman
suffering from ptsd from um sexual abuse
and it's a really really smart
interesting look
at that i'm gonna go with the classic
and go with texas chainsaw monster
i'm going to go with basket case
but nice
i also
would love to see
maybe you prano make um stationary
massacre in this makeup my favorite fake
video nasty yeah
yeah i'm not a massive video nasty fan
um ironically i'm gonna plug the one
that piranha plugs all the time that she
hasn't done which is don't scare jessica
to death which is a she's a great a
great i mean she i wouldn't have watched
it she obviously had to watch it because
brianna told me like but um it's a it's
a fine it's a fine scary weird
feminist
non-feminist